greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by zip recruiter listen you know how
challenging it is to hire somebody it's
hard to find qualified candidates it
takes too much time too many applicants
zip recruiter makes it nice and easy you
work in the URL and that's it you're
gonna zip recruit a doc Tom slash Church
you understand me
zip recruiter send your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there
do me a favor we results like that it's
no wonder that zip recruiter it's the
highest rating hiring site in America so
right now do me a favor you're not doing
nothing you're looking for an applicant
go to Japan cooler calm right now and
slash Church CH you are CH and find the
applicant you've been looking for number
two um listen all I know is one thing I
got a wife I got a kid I don't cook but
there's people that cook at the house if
I was if I was a single guy and find a
girlfriend she's busy blue apron is the
answer blue apron Lee what do you think
about blue I love it I just got another
box on Wednesday but they couldn't make
it easier every recipes delicious it's
always new I love the way / don't me a
favor listen to me it's nice
the ingredients are proportioned
perfectly and they delivered right to
your door
blue apron makes dinner quick easy and
yet insanely tasty skip a meal planning
and get straight to cooking with blue
apron so do me a favor check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals free you like Joey what are you
talking about listen I'm gonna give you
your first three meals for free at blue
apron com / Joey again that's blue apron
com / Joey kick this [__] meal with
five [__] dirty guys from Boston
don't let heroin in the [__] house ya
filthy this is it AJ be in the
[__] house
filthy before we even get started ask
your questions once it's been taunting
me for I should ask you a last happen
what is the difference between
journalism and gossip well there's no
difference per se but journalism
is the that the talent and the practice
you need to apply when you're when
you're tracking down rumors that people
tend to believe to be gossip put it this
way
it's like saying what's the dip I don't
get into analogies you've got to be a
good journalist to do the job of a good
gossip columnist just like you've got to
be a good journalist to do the job of a
good crime reporter or you know whatever
the beat is most most stories we latch
on to today whether it's something at
the White House or something that's
happening in show biz what-have-you
generally speaking a lot of them begin
in the gossip columns a lot of them
start as a rumor and the gossip
columnist is usually the first person on
the front lines to track down those
rumors and when you track them down if
they kind of fall out of your
jurisdiction like if they're bigger than
the gossip column when I was at the
Daily News then they get pushed up to
the front of the paper and my byline
wouldn't go on it because you'd give it
to a reporter who covers page two three
and four like those are different
reporters those are bigger guys with
bigger resumes we may be just as good in
terms of how we write but they got
different jobs there their City City
reporters if there was a if there's a
story breaking about the corruption in
the government local government it
wouldn't go in the gossip column but I
might hear that rumor I might report it
out get the story right and then give it
to the guys up front and it becomes a
page three story a page two which is the
biggest story so a good gossip columnist
is the same thing as anybody it's you've
got to be a good journalist it's very
different now though because now there's
very few people who are literally
breaking stories I still break stories
every week in my podcast but nowadays
there are so many outlets of things
being written somebody website somebody
[__] the Internet is full of stories
if you don't know who broke this story
where it began if it's being rewritten
from a paper in [__] Canada you don't
know we just read [__] and know
kids who wrote it no one cares who's the
reporter who broke it but 20-30 years
ago it was very important oh this is so
and so story it was broken the Daily
News it was a big story like page six
yeah paper comes up with paid six like
paid six is like Kanye West did [__]
blow his [__] way yeah well that page
six is is the New York Post premiere
gossip but it's real like it's legit
it's not a [__] think about those no
no no because the this is not the
National Enquirer or star magazine star
magazine has absolute fake stories in it
mixed in with real stories The Enquirer
is the same thing although you know I
hate to [__] on them because there are
stories in The Enquirer that
traditionally got things right forever
The Enquirer led the nation in the oj
coverage it doesn't matter who's that it
doesn't matter what paper or what
magazine it matters what reporter works
there you don't I mean like when I was
writing for radar okay radar might have
a reputation for [__] just putting
[__] up there but if it's a good
reporter and you'd happen to have good
contacts and you can get to the meat of
things then it doesn't matter who you
write for it matters who's writing the
story that's what's been lost lately
no one cares who's writing the story
they just they just stories appear
everywhere and Twitter
[__] Instagram Facebook there's
stories everywhere and they're written
by people look I used to make a lot of
money as a journalist which is not
something that generally happens but I
did and then I made a lot of money as a
magazine writer and but Popeye 10 grand
an article for this Tangra now if I
approach a magazine with an article idea
I they might offer me 1500 because
there's so many [__] idiots who just
want their name in print that magazines
go whoa my pay him 10 grand this guy'll
do it for [__] on a thousand it's old
it's all [__] up now it's all but
there's so much more outlets yeah I know
that's the problem it's become less it's
like that's like the fonts like you're
opening up more teams in the NFL you get
shitty talent right you get these to be
20 gossip columnist now there are 20,000
like just to be a gossip columnist in LA
well okay it never was one like to go
out at night mingle and [__] give
yourself like a
her name on the [__] page Allah
that's I that's all no one no one's ever
done that that alot and go last night I
went to economy store and the economy
was electric but the underlying energy
is fueled by drugs and what I did it's
so weird like how to be a gossip
columnist in New York everyday Joe we
were I was Alan it's not like a dick
here but in the 90s I was as powerful a
name that if I called you you [__]
stomach was in knots because that meant
tomorrow your names gonna mean a paper
and a million people are gonna read it
and it's it's very different than la la
I never had a gossip column they never
did they have TMZ now which is all of a
TV but they never had a reporter going
around town getting [__] because people
in Hollywood but you get you get you get
enamored with Hollywood lifestyle and
you you don't want to talk about those
people are right about them what is TMZ
TMZ the gossip more no what's it gets a
journalist then get they tell you the
other [__] journalism is just there it's
all journalism they're all practicing
journalism they're just they're there
they're good reporters they're good at
getting to the root of things and
breaking stories or covering stories
that are happening now whether it's
celebrity death celebrity overdose
Harvey Levin is was brilliant with what
he did with TMZ it was brilliant it's
thought of with a kid with a [__]
camera outside of the courtroom I think
at the menendez trial or OJ trial so God
would a camera out there asking
questions as people came and he started
to make friends with Shapiro he made
friend they thought they recognized they
got the camera a little camera and
Harvey Levin saw that was Harvey was a
reporter at the time he saw the way
these people are gravitating toward this
guy with the camera and talking to it
and Harvey said that's this is suck this
is something because these people who
have something really big going on a
gravitating told there's nobody but the
camera was being nice to them so from
that moment at the OJ trial I believe it
was Harvey invented this whole I'll put
a bunch of people around California at
all the hotspots with cameras and the
stars will talk to us initially
they didn't like it initially the stars
hated it and it was now they love it now
when they see now TMZ cameras and TMZ
people get preferential treatment you
what they want to be on TMZ with the new
outfit the new girlfriend they know
whatever the [__] it is it's a whole
different thing now now they use TMZ as
an accessory to help them get bigger and
more more known but it's all journalism
I'm not gonna [__] on the reporters
there they do their job but Harvey's got
things wired he's got people in County
Clerk offices you've got people in the
court systems the minute someone gets
busted the minute someone files for
divorce but there's a phone call to TMZ
and they get it right away
wait to me it's how it sounds like Joey
you're kind of asking maybe look it's a
subject matter so like if it's stuff
about Kanye and Kim Kardashian that's
yeah that's maybe more gossipy the whole
situation I'm a police sergeant in a big
precinct in Manhattan right and James
Gandolfini god rest her soul gets pulled
over with 20 G's hmm 20 grams of blow
and he like cop calls it in in my mama
and right away I pick up the phone and I
give a scoop to somebody within the hour
a checks and then blow so I get dropped
off at my thing regardless of this if
not in regular not I never we never paid
any newspapers don't pay [__] the people
who pay are the tabloids the Enquirer
the star no a guy like you you look a
little [__] yeah but no much
lamorne the god he became friends with
that one journalist guy John Miller did
white dude that's still around our stop
is 10 steps behind all those all those
gangs crazy that when you become friends
with a journalist like that yeah works
for you in different ways I can feed
[__] into that pipeline yeah yeah sure
you like to feed [__] into that pipeline
so why are they coming you if you're not
giving the money why they why why are
they coming in giving you scoot here's
what you have to understand people look
how many secrets have you been told and
you kept under your [__] jacket and
never told anybody else
there's a saying three can keep a secret
if two are dead people talk people want
to tell you what they know they burst at
the seams to tell you
they [__] we just spent 40 minutes
talking about stories about this guy
this drug dealer what I did with Winona
Ryder Sean Penn Vince while we were al
pacino we told stories for 40 minutes
before the show started that are all
secrets and we couldn't wait to get it
out of our [__] system there's
millions of people like that I'll have
stories so if you show up and you hang
around and you wait long enough and you
get oiled up with them and sit in the
booth with them and they like you
eventually you hear those secrets now
you don't want to [__] the bed and run
away right away and and and burn a
friendship you just take it in you take
it in you take it in and then you start
to peel off the stories then you start
to get to know the lay of the land
oh this guy knows these people I think
this guy's a good contact for that [__]
so you put it in your [__] rolodex in
your head and then as you go along you
know maybe don't print that story about
Sean Penn doing blow a blah blah blah
but just keep it in your head and then
down the road it's gonna matter it's
gonna it's gonna lead to something we
talked about Johnny Goomba Johnny and
scores right you know like I knew all
the characters and every restaurant
every night club every know what he is
was this going on it scores scores was a
98 the people what happened scores was
the strip club Mecca in America forever
it was in Manhattan but for a good I'd
say 10 years it was it was just
everybody who went to New York who was
anybody went to scores they just the
whole OJ trial went every athlete went
and I mean they [__] the girls you
know George Clooney would stay at a
hotel but he'd send [__] a car for
the the hottest five and they'd make
sure the five hottest girls would get to
George at the hotel everybody worked
through scores it was like it was
unbelievable it was like the studio 54
of the 90s right so what happened what
scores was scores happen to be both the
Gambino and the Genovese family had
their hands on scores they both took
money out of that joint with a what they
call a friendly like they both took that
into that joint and there was a couple
of tough Albanian kids who would call
the Albanian thunking of thought oh and
the Italians the Mafia
scaly Albanians because they don't give
a [__] and the Albanians a couple of
brothers named Simon and Victor de Dodge
crazy [__] showed up it's cause
one night and they would say you know
guys we gotta close and they'd say now
wait now don't close we're here like you
know they'd [__] shoot a gun in the
ceiling crazy [__] Cowboys and you know
scores at this point there's one any
trouble cuz they got a lot of things
they're doing that are [__] under the
table and illegal like we don't don't
shoot have done in this [__] place
it's hot don't do that you know and
these Cowboys he's shooting [__] you
know
anyhow so one night there was an
argument believe it or not all the
[__] over world of a rum of a Hulk
Hogan of a [__] wrestling these guys
are arguing with some other guys was
about Hulk Hogan and World Wrestling
Federation but Popeye and it got heated
these guys got mad you gotta go it's
10:00 to 5:00 [__] you I'm not leaving
Hulk Hogan like like kids and one
brother had a gun one brother had a
knife and on the way out to doorman was
stabbed and shot and the two brothers
got away so big manhunt I'm in the
hospital for back surgery and I get a
call from the city desk AJ I'm just
coming out of my [__] fog I got the
morphine in me AJ rich Rosen you know I
know you read [__] New York Hospital
look this there's a there's two kids
from scores I don't one who doorman who
got shot up last night you know you
don't think about who this might be
and in my stupor I said yeah it's the
albanian brothers I'm guarantee it
holiday I said then I said their names
so now I'm a gossip columnist but I knew
who the killers could be The Daily News
took that and ran of course I was right
now one brother jump in the Hudson River
and swam to Jersey crazy [__] guy he
escaped he was on the lam forever they
couldn't get him the other brother they
got right away but they eventually
caught the other guy he's doing [__]
life the whole thing I wrote an article
in Playboy about this whole thing and so
about a year ago
this is 1997 I believe so a year ago
it's 20 years later I'm on Instagram but
fine I see I got a message on Instagram
from simon to dodge de da j i think it's
Dadaji to die to die to die i don't like
what if i why's he won't talk to me i
was petrified like this is a [__]
murderer hey I love the love you talk to
me I really could talk to you and I I
said ma I go my wife I said what what
she goes will call myself why I don't
want a murderer introduced I got kids
now who needs this [__] I called them I
just want to tell you I read the play
bar article you handled it like a man
you were really honest about this in
that but that the DA and he said you
know we're innocent oh yeah of course
they're gonna say that um it's a whole
weird thing they claimed it didn't
happen the way it happened but one
brother is serving life and a sister
says that the brother who's serving life
is innocent and the brother who's free
actually did it and it's torn apart
their family so it's it you know these
things happen when [__] brother was
making the girls done to the girl look
the shakedowns happened from the top
right down the [__] the guys who Paul
cause have to [__] call money up the
guys who took coats cost money up to the
managers the security guys everybody
coughed up to the top everybody the
girls crazy shake down city I mean these
girls would make you know if you go to
if you're a Wall Street guy you didn't
pay cash you put on your card he was
funny money right so for every [__]
hundred dollars of cash you'd spend 150
on your card and every girl you know was
all that the poor girls would work you
think they'd make a hundred bucks but
they got a shake then they got to pay
the [__] with the house mom they
gotta pay the security guy they got a
pitiful guy who walked them to the car
they had a little water the mobsters had
a little wired I mean they they just
they made the money the most but but
John Gotti junior would walk in there
and get a [__] envelope and then the
the Jenna VC guy would do the same thing
and it was a it was a it was an urn for
a long time they were both earning no
other it's still it it's not it's all
over now no no it's not the joint
anymore it's done I even watched
a couple weeks ago i got home i MC head
on copperhead and the beginning a collar
yeah yeah that's right
let's now the toy Rappaport come out of
the scores let me tell you some joey it
was the it was the you know it was the
preeminent place she had to be it was it
was the studio 54 of the 90s you had to
go yeah there's so many stories i don't
know where to begin with schools i mean
but this way one night this is a small
story one night you know a picture for
the Pittsburgh Pirates Doug Drabek walks
in and he's [__] get weight you know
and I have athletes who come every night
so if they were playing the Mets or the
Yankees the staff at scores will get
them hammered because the next day is a
game and we'd bet the home team
so Drabek comes in he's pitching
tomorrow and it's she's pitching on a
Sunday afternoons and day game and
Saturday nights he's wake we're getting
him the word got out get Trebek [__]
up who's got blow who's got this what
does he want everybody goes to see
Drabek and at four o'clock in the
morning we had to lift him up and put
him in the [__] Town Car lift him up
he's a [__] major league pitcher we
called everybody we knew all the wise
guys we don't get on the Mets tomorrow
our Drabek can't walk he's thrown up in
the street it's all [__] done the
Mets are gonna cover and we all went to
bed and the mobster guys got on this
heavy you sure you sure yeah heavy and
the next day I wake up and I hear Doug
Drabek pitching a masterpiece eighth
inning in the Med sir [__] losing now
seven to like it didn't you know there
are animals they're animals Charles but
all's hopefully for the Knicks would
[__] be face down sleeping on the
carpet during the playoffs against
Indiana against Reggie Miller against
[__] you know against George knocked
out from too much [__] liquor and what
have you
the next day they're playing a [__]
game like Namath oh yeah those are the
days John name but George was for all of
ya guy went and bought his own bar
yeah yes a natural would go up there I
know that's how crazy that was uh my
sister husband and a brother with my
brother law were dating and he said I
want to take you to John Amos bar they
one of their fur
States they went I think was called
bachelors fall and name it was there and
my brother-in-law was a big athlete and
he he Mosley's up the name it was
[__] the king you know win or
whatever the [__] he's wearing and my
net my brother-in-law's talking he was a
Joe you know dance with my girlfriend
and Namath danced with my sister and for
my brother-in-law that was like the
crowning you know
Namath dancing with my you know
meanwhile he was it was just it was
insane that place everybody was getting
[__] laid name is may Matt Namath and
Mickey Mantle it but two of the same
kind of guys they would just stay out
late get [__] up there's a lot of
athletes of the day Jason Giambi on the
Yankees one that scores one night the
World Series just ended with him with
the Marlins beat the Yankees that was a
horrible showing for the Yankees
terrible and uh I'm wearing a Yankee cap
my nephews the old Yankee cap and this
is this [__] Giambi
and his eyes are [__] he's dude it
he's [__] out of his mind and you
know look at Giambi I should ask him
where he got his [__] coke look at
him he's out of his mind so he goes in
the restroom I follow him
and then he's [__] piss in there hey
what's up Jason hey man you know he has
no idea that I used to write guys he's
no I am and I go bro
and and the game before he didn't get up
to bat like we had Jason Giambi as a
pinch-hitter who was an animal and he
decided I don't to bat and the Yankee
fans were like why wouldn't Jason Giambi
bat what the [__] wrong with him he's
a slugger so I go I go Jason what the
[__] happened then I tweeted him back he
goes dude we're in [__] South Beach
we [__] out of our minds I couldn't
stand up and you go oh my god us [__]
squares and sitting on watching the
World Series and these guys are going on
it suck in South Beach I can't stand up
I got bat like the Yankees just got
Jason Giambi got too [__] up in the
nightlife in South Beach that's why he
didn't bat the newspapers will tell you
that a good reporter a good journalist
I'll tell you that because he would have
been there and seen it
that's what gossip columnist do they
would have been there at the nightclubs
and said is John me getting high yeah I
would have contacted all the coquilles
who's supplying Giambi and I want to
know ahead of time like when do i
could'nt on the Mets missed the [__]
World Series parade and he was sweating
like a pig
at Newsday back of the day there was a
guy that was calling in anonymous tips
to the desk saying like puddings on
cocaine and this is like the 80s we
people like he's on cocaine what do you
mean a bazooka
Dwight Gooden he's an athlete it was
unheard of and this guy was right Gooden
a strawberry out of their [__] minds
but it's crazy the people that will tell
you things like this is why life is
[__] crazy that's why I asked about
gossip column especially in New York
City I don't know how it works it's only
New York City and New York not LA it's
new you know we know everything you
can't and I can't imagine now with
cameras could you imagine yo could you
imagine I can't imagine I'd be lined up
so I know for a fact like I know for a
fact like I was a kid I was 21 years old
I was working at the Sheridan Center and
you know Van Halen was staying up saw
God you know like I forgot about you
know I just remember different now that
information could work in a lot of ways
if you may you a reporter if you were no
no no no for me oh I know you
yeah exactly there you go you come in
you give me a package every time that's
all stay in here that's all no I don't
know ten cases of [__] Jack Daniels
of the VIP I know that's an item they
said that's something weird or at the
same time you know whether it's hookers
cuz that Hotel knows everything what I
know there's the saddest thing about
comedy what I go to a town when I go to
a town and I go check into a hotel by
the second day somebody at that hotel
will tell me a story that I didn't ask
isn't that same about a comedy that's
the secrets I'm telling you because
every comic stays yeah but people told
people love to talk you know whether
whether he [__] like the horror no
much cold exactly wore out the table you
know we could heard the chopping in the
other room was telling me that there was
a comic that was supposed to leave on
Sunday and on Wednesday he was still in
the hotel room it's a college town yeah
I got paid like sixty thousand dollars
to do the show's over the weekend and
there was a college girl at a strip club
that drove him crazy
feed them pills the club didn't even
know that he was still in town and then
the hotel called the club on Thursday
and said can you guys come over here we
want to show you before we build you
look at the [__] tape oh my god crack
it was all about entertainment chopped
up chopped it up unbelievable you know
so when little things like that that is
great these little things in a hotel
room you know when when when up you know
again I work at the [__] what's the
best hotel in New York City she has them
that the the plaza in a there is almost
so many them I'm a bellman at the plant
Tina oh yeah they do I see [__] Sean
Penn walking yeah and every three hours
I see a different Asian woman walk
upstairs hey there you go gotta believe
who's here you can try these food like a
[__] you know what I do is
that's how it's done you know what I do
as a reporter don't I do I had a guy I
had a guy now we didn't pay people the
newspapers just don't pay it so that's a
lie we had no money to but they would
never say I need a hundred bucks to pay
the doorman we don't do that and very
few stories came from doorman or
hairdressers but in the case where you
meet a guy who works at Hotel or
whatever capacity you go yeah I really
like to hear what you know this is the
[__] hot hotel this is the Soho grand
or whatever it is this is where
everybody's going yeah I'd like to hear
your [__] every week what can I do for
you I real I'd like to see the [__]
Knicks now and then
no problem I'll get Nick tickets for you
no problem so on my corporate card I
[__] banging out two games with the
Knicks he goes to see the Knicks in the
nice section and that guy's indebted
I mean people people will talk when you
put 20 bucks in their path forget about
a [__] scene the Knicks play the 90s
it was I had that I I had this [__] to
grease their wheels and they would just
talk and I'll tell you speaking about
chopping up at a hotel I was in South
Beach once when I was really on top of
my game and the e-channel was running a
show called the gossip show where it was
the precursor to TMZ you probably never
saw there was a bunch of journalists and
we talked to the camera and blah blah
blah and I'm in South Beach you know
when it was just thought to get built up
I'm on [__] Washington Boulevard or
one of those Art Deco spots and all
night I hear this
with the credit card on the [__]
table I'm like Jesus Christ who the [__]
is next to me and like a day later I'm
about I'm waiting for this person to
leave so I can look who's leaving and
it's [__] Kate Moss and she's a
famous cokehead and I don't know she
must have recognized me because I was
pretty visible back then and I just said
to her you know at some point today I
gotta have some of this [__] you're
taking and she laughed and I think she
knew what that meant that meant that if
you give me someone to [__] you're
taking no one's gonna know you're doing
this in this hotel room
you don't mean we're fine all right but
I need some of that [__] and she gave me
some of that [__] and I never wrote that
story that Kate Moss was in the [__]
Cleveland or hotel shopping line till
four o'clock in the morning I wouldn't
do that to her but it'd be nice to have
a little [__] taste of your [__] okay
milady and she gave me some and I never
wrote the story so if you're if you're
out enough and you're around enough
you'll you'll get to [__] play the
game and extort people or or get people
in positions compromising positions
where they need to tell you things I'm
sure I can help you you know what can I
do for you it's just just uh you know
it's just a lot of [__] but at its core
you're a journalist and you're good at
what you do and you're gonna write a
story so what can we do before I go
write this know when you you got a
degree in just sure yeah yeah I did I
that's how I started like I would dream
of being Oscar Madison yeah discovering
the [__] Lakers that's it and
everything that is the lake I don't know
nothing about the Lakers I understand
but that's what I would do is like
everything Lakers I start are you match
towards the lake is that why they need
the draft the guard would you would
[__] want to slice your vein within a
year now Walt listen the guys I came up
with Tom Verducci rich jhemini Peter
King someone to get Wireless Matthews I
still do
we all came up in the eighties we all
started as part-time employees at
Newsday on Long Island and all these guy
Tom Verducci calls the playoff game
isn't [__] an NBC you know he's a
major [__] Talent Wallace math all
these guys I'm mentioning are huge they
stayed in the game and God bless him I
was like how many times can I hear an
athlete go I'm just you take it one game
at a time man you know I'm gonna [__]
do my thing you know we gotta get the
hit we counted we got way how I can't
keep hearing that [__] yeah it's fun to
see some games it's fun to see the best
athletes run up and down the court but
when you go in the locker room and you
[__] say hey man talk about that play
in the second quarter it's the same [__]
and I don't want to get on planes and go
to [__] North Carolina and
Indianapolis and [__] call I don't
want to do that but no I'm gonna stay in
New York and cover the [__] glitzy
glamorous [__] I'm talking to you your
way we talk like neck tutorial knit the
Torah lives and dies by the yeah I know
I see Nikolas yeah you know I'm the same
way why he doesn't do an article like so
me like that I'm not talking about
[__] interview and that was a beat
before all I said I would [__] die
that's listen journalism to me is also
Mike Wallace like my father's right is
this journalism with no stretch the best
journalist which buttons I love all that
that's the best I like you know in a way
you could say that what goes on with
Anthony Bourdain God rest his soul he
was a journalist journalist he's one of
my heroes while my his the people who
show you the world right through their
[__] eyes people gain trust from you
if I tell you that this is happening and
a year from now it happens now you'll
like me more as a journalist why sure I
see like when somebody goes up to a job
an athlete's have I'm not answering
questions you burnt me yeah why would
you burn me Wow if you're trying to get
your name up it's a delicate dance you
know as you also got a bright you also
got to be really honest about stories if
somebody dogs it and as being a jerk-off
or whatever you've got to have the balls
to write that story and show up in the
locker room the next day and see him
again like if you okay you're an athlete
you're telling jokes at the [__]
Laugh Factory whatever I'm a journalist
and I go show talk about that the third
joke in the the first four minutes he
said the joke about cheat you bust each
can explain why that's important to you
if you hear that 20 [__] times a week
oh shoot listen okay now I got to do my
job I got to fill the column inches for
the paper I don't even want to ask you
the question I don't want to ask you you
don't want to answer it that's sports
writing I don't want to ask you you
don't want to answer every like 10 to 12
games there's a great game where you go
this is amazing you hit a home run that
was 500 feet you just passed a record
that DiMaggio's there's always something
to make sure you get happy again
you're gonna playoff run but I would
also redeem that athlete if I burned an
athlete because he wasn't doing the job
on a Tuesday night and then he came out
of his coma on Sunday Tuesday he did
others like Bernard King you know
turnaround baseline jumper yeah I just
you know here's another guy that was
doing everything Bernard was an animal
that was a kid you know I know for a
fact they shipped him up the Golden
State right then he became the comeback
play of the year off and then he went
back to [__] the Knicks I know just
leveled New York he has the king of
[__] New York they are like somebody
like that so like I always love
journalism I just want to know the
difference between and I know how gossip
started there's no difference especially
everybody everybody everybody
understands the the the the the
principles of journalism whether you're
writing whether you're a court reporter
or a street crime reporter or a gossip
columnist or a music critic you all know
the the principles of journalism but
don't ever think that the person who's
working in the gossip column is not as
good a reporter
as the person who's covering stories for
Washington DC [__] because I'm
[__] years removed from being in a
newsroom and I see what these [__]
are doing at the White House and the
[__] stories they're writing and I
want to scream what they're doing is not
journalism for instance Omarosa is so
[__] popular now because she has
these tapes and these things of trumping
it did he say negative okay he probably
said [__] we've all said [__] we used
to say IDI meenie miney moe catch a
[__] by the toe
does that mean I'm a racist we played
that game it's horrible we live we grew
up in those times I'm sure he said it
once in a while I'm sure we also were in
love with the same black girl we also
were in love with the same black girl's
family he proposed marriage the same
girl we both dated
there's nothing racist about him if
you're gonna say that he said the [__]
word that makes him a racist according
to Don Lemon at CNN and other [__]
if you call a black guy stupid you're
racist he called the Bron James stupid
his racist he calls every white guy
[__] sneaky slimy jerk-off shorty why
if you make fun of a black guy you're
racist it's the same thing toughen up
stop being such [__] Don Lemon
remember when you had a bottle where I
hate down bottle right if we took the
became a [__] chase yeah [__] that's
exactly unbelievable that even Chinese
people will use Chinatown you want
negative you want to get young on you
have fun you have fun with model rocket
ah you break the bottle rocket you light
it they become [__] chaser and you're
sitting there going oh my god listen
nice seventies in full effect there you
know exactly you know I think I'm pretty
sure no new that who know
you know why I'm walk Fuhrman looks like
an [__] for the og truck because he
actually said with a straight face I've
never used the n-word and you're looking
you're a cop in Los Angeles who's never
said the aunt get the [__] so in other
words you're not credible at all of
course you've said that word cops
especially say that word white cops now
is Mark Fuhrman erases I probably say
he's close to the one but I don't think
Trump is not when you're in love with
the chick who's part black and no it
doesn't no no it doesn't they got to
stop believing
Omarosa who's a [__] dog and a piece
of [__] and a conniving mean filthy
person who who everybody left out in the
media Donald Trump's bring him Amaro's
in the White House what's wrong she's
worthless and now they're looking at her
is the biggest [__] story you know
whatever you samurai sir what else do
you got you got more tapes it makes me
sick so you got more tapes in Prince
Prince and that [__] ball that chick
had a tape with whether that little
[__] you believe that probably you
don't want everybody in that town has a
tape recorder on in that town you're out
of your mind okay good point
I take people in the news with people I
grew up in North Bergen New Jersey where
the tape recorder is was essential they
tape everything they have everything I
have them with all the people's houses
and they had the tape like when you went
to a bookie joint they had that the
phone with the plug into the phone
record right so I call you and press
record
oh you yeah and there's a microphone on
the thing when the old days from these
phones here right I would put a you know
when you fall into a numbers bank yeah
and you call them to a bookie getting
paid the 10 [__] all done I know
back to the way for you they always are
whatever you call a book in the 70s they
always had to take always yeah my mother
had tons of tape recorders yeah at the
numbers joy yeah
same reason yes when they call in so I
like I have friends I grew up with and
everything was based on tapes that's in
Canada it's a corrupt town yeah
everything is based on tapes mmm
so you know in the old
is the super Etsy now it's all
completely different like I was right
the story in my book the other day about
my first encounter in New York my first
encounter in New York was on we lived on
89th and Riverside Drive all right we
had my father had just died and me and
my mom lived there and I didn't know my
mom had the building-wide
right I had the building why I don't
know what that meant that he [__] the
phone rings at 6:00 in the morning and
I'm awake watching pop by out whatever
right door marks they put it off she had
the bar in Union City oh yeah the super
girls put your mom on the phone
and like wake my mom mommy it's super
super yeah I think that he said
something my mom slammed the phone ran
up split open the [__] closet took a
bag out really we used to have a balcony
in the back in the kitchen and she slid
the thing open and she dumped it loudly
underneath and two minutes later you
heard police open the hole I was five
wow they said is both on the cats and
they separated us and but by that time I
had gone I had loved PS 66 used to take
you to the the to five precinct the Sun
to all really would fingerprint you how
you lost really try to shoot a gun oh my
god one day my mom came home this is
what goes on in this house this is
cocaine this is AG marijuana all those
places you go there number book my head
almost exploded I guess you think if
anybody gives you this on the street say
no wow this is what we do in this house
and but then she took our little statue
of the three month yeah of course yeah
you know the here no see you know this
is what you live by this is the rule you
don't know nothing I know so they busted
into the house two weeks later and then
they separate us
you know I my mom spoke great English
yeah but right away Cuban people and
Italian people yeah biggest week's grave
English client well the cops get there
oh no no no no no no no English no
English and you become the interpreter
by proxy right and they're telling you
no no yeah tell them they're wrong
I don't know nothing it's mean man on
fire no no say nobody knows nothing's
bad now I know it's fantastic
hey guess what
they separated you like to do with the
border yeah [__] law
they separate the kids for the night I
put me in a bunch of question I play
like the half retiling Reid oh yeah they
put us back in the couch and they left
and I never forget my mom like 20 mins
later the super came up isn't one I'm so
sorry my mom game like a half horse and
my mind live a my mom talk and they
don't study it because they tapped your
phone I was in those days they would tap
your phone the rice of it and they had
to put a tag on it in those days to say
your phone was tapped amazing that's how
you know your phone would stop you went
to your thing and you broke up in the
phone thing and if you looked at a thing
a little tag
really yeah the 70s and 60s they had to
tell you not only your tag like I got a
letter still at the house which I should
be getting a lot more a lot more you
know if you call into a Wyatt that and
they settle the case after the case is
settled maybe they get you they have to
send you paperwork that tells you you
want a Wyatt oh yeah I don't know that
so the feds get you on a wiretap or
they're like the state prosecutor's
office they have to let you know I used
to get those letters for use in fact I
still got one at the house that somebody
made me bring on the Rogan podcast how
they showed Rogan that's funny and it
was a Genovese guy that I still talk
does it this yeah yeah we're friends and
he called me to do a benefit for them
and like a week later I was like what
the [__] is this really just to let you
know oh you wanna why I think about the
thing about when they get like my buddy
Chico was when we were living together
in the city and he was working scores
and we had that you know it's like
Donnie Brasco that that movie is so real
because me is the journalist a powerful
journalist
well I they looked at me when if you're
Italian and you have a high profile job
that the guys will find you because you
can make money with you they'll find you
and if you like me you'll figure out a
way to make money with the guys you know
I did i I figured out a way that I can
confirm all parties for them at their
club has been still write my column and
say great party at this club tonight and
they would give me $500 for the party I
still did that which is not ethical
but I did it and she goes with me and
he's getting all sorts of trouble and I
go and back in upon Monday in Madison
Avenue and there's Chico and a couple of
guys wouldn't break is on you know the
[__] feds and I see them and she
gives me a look like you know I'm sorry
about this I said I'm sorry and they go
his name is Tim he's real man hey Tim
you know and he's [__] feds they only
ask questions they know the answer to
you know they're not stupid they don't
[__]
Tim you know you don't Joe Diaz now I
launched ideas and I get the [__]
book out open the book and there's a
picture you and Joe Diaz together yeah
and he goes yeah I know him but I don't
know the guy I never talk to him Coco
then they take ya right then they go you
don't talk to him take out the recorder
they press play and there's you and
Chico talking like you're [__]
friends but this is me with a legitimate
job and I'm looking at him and the feds
are on him they know everything and
eventually he had to leave and I had to
go down to the West Village we have to
separate here an organized crime file it
was all it was insane but they you know
when when the feds come into your life
like a phone tap or whatever the [__] it
gets real creep and then and then on top
of the feds Chico had tough guys after
until he had made guys after him and it
was a guy named Sal Scala I don't know
where he is or what [__] position he
is now but back in the day he was a
tough guy was a [__] shooter killer
and the word was because Chico the
somebody Menace sort of feds come in my
apartment that I vouch for Chico so I
was in trouble and chica was gonna get
hit cuz he was and we knew South scallop
was the guy that was gonna do it for
about six months we would always go into
a restaurant or nightclub and in the
middle of having fun we go south Scala
says hello nobody [__] do the fake
knife you know I mean
like what's dangerous but we started
laughing about I take a butter knife to
your neck scallops I was alone you know
but I can't explain it
it was thrilling but [__] scary
what have somebody looking for you to
know that someone's out there yeah I
mean we go down to the Jersey Shore in
the winter and live in a cabin with no
electricity to be on the lam I have to
work at the news I loved it I know you
see he is I love and I would hide right
in front of them and they would hide the
plain sight I would hire you mean you
loved it it's a thrill night from 70
from 80 to 95 it's a thrill my mind I
got off on somebody looking for you see
what I'm saying I don't I don't like
your honor sometimes like I'm tired and
I just look the mailman knock on my door
put the packages down can't hurt you man
I can't hurt sure he's gonna give you a
honking all along putting bets over
people oh yeah not paying them and then
they're like they gonna send a guy to
break your legs
yeah you know I had like yes when I went
back to North Bergen 84 I want on a tear
of fronting and not pan and then they'll
buy that they would sell the paper to
somebody else which means I owe you five
thousand right [__] he hates me so
much
yeah he's gonna give you the five so he
[__] me so he beat me up that's
awesome I like I got to that point
people have your death oh my god I mean
it was crazy that is where I had the
protection law of a cop loved me so
everybody knew if you touch that Specht
you're gonna have to deal with this guy
eventually I had a cop so crazy and then
it's funny because this is a different
situation that we'll finish this thing
on the hunt Mike the guy who baptized me
yeah the guy who threw water Church yeah
with his wife and he was you know to
this day it's it's a painful situation
for me why I play now [__] ah it's the
guy that the guy at Bass Roger you
[__] when I got old or my father died
he would pick me up every Saturday
that's hardcore
every
how they take me to 42nd Street a movie
theater listen get me high he would want
me no the fact the guy who threw water
on you and the [__] like listen to
almost about love dismal destroy the
floor yeah this is like a journalistic
why he was for four or five years every
Saturday he picked me up at nine in the
morning
wherever I was told my mom see you later
and he was a savage he would take me
somewhere
gobby lon
no I don't know nah be long Caballero
Wow cowboy he would pick me up who's a
Cuban guy that grew up with my dad they
played like baseball together his kids
and he baptized me my dad died and in
the Cuban and Italian culture when you
have godparents yeah and something
happens they automatically have a step
up right away
yeah Godfather has to come in and go no
matter what that's the word you give
yeah when you throw that water and
that's the word you give we were tight
how about I was 10 and then even go to
Miami he was like a coke sale whatever
he was doing he would disappear then
come back well he was titled meal when
him and my mother when my mother died he
got tight with me and he did check in
with me for a few weeks and then in my
world in his world we we lost
communication I actually forgot about
and in 84 when I was going through my
[__] yeah my mother was definitely
dead now my realization that this ain't
coming back I went off the deep end
yeah and I bumped into a Monday I'll
never forget that he goes look at the
shape what happened you know he took me
this lesson usually bought me a winter
jacket I got mean guys that's how
pathetic I was 84 he bought me a winter
jacket a couple of sweaters
what had it I didn't want that I want to
hand that yeah yeah which I was not
gonna get you I was going to used to
snorkel of course so I became family
with him never go to his house and Eve
he would talk he never offered me a
bedroom mm-hmm you know so kind of like
I was getting pissed off me right and
then one day goes listening you need to
make money okay I got a way to help
yeah sell some ounces and I would sell
ounces and I play them I play them seven
months I play them you know if I told
him one have the money Thursday I have a
Wednesday and then one day I took a big
chunk from him he says I gotta leave for
the weekend you want more like you know
what leave me the amount
give me like 500 to start and I went on
a tear gonna pay them gone he wasn't
like the regular people had burnt before
yeah he hooked him with that sure and he
hunted me down
I didn't end the final result was
October of 84 and in June of 85 I was in
front of a white castle taking a bus
with a bag headed in Newark Airport and
he pulled up railing in the motorcycle
he was still looking for me Wow
and he said the next time I see he goes
you caught me off guard
I've been looking at people with Tommy
all he comes into bars all the time ah
itself [__] it's scary and he goes the
next time I see you I'm gonna put a
bullet in you I disappeared to Miami one
91 I was back I went to West New York
and I had half his money
all right and I went to my stepfather
and I go where's God and he goes bro he
don't want to see the only thing he
wants to do is put a bullet in yeah and
then when I had a kid I the guy that
baptized my kid's name was Pete lead but
Merrill Maguire we don't speak anymore
but he pulled me aside when he was dog I
was in Fort Lee about [__] coke with
these guys hot [__] and your name came
up
it's people looking for you yeah like
whatever you didn't oh my god he's
sticking up on that that's bad but the
biggest one I did was 85 I took this guy
for everything and he lived in West New
York so the word was out I was in
Colorado but I was really in Cresskill
New Jersey and I was going through the
city seeing his friends but he was a
[__] western yo guy that wouldn't
leave Western yeah such a a coke dealer
yeah yeah ooh and it's so funny how you
know I just got off on it and then when
they would like I had with this guy 60
[__] grandpa blah oh and I just took
off in 87 that's death money you're
gonna get killed
in 87 I just took off yeah 86 went
through 86 is 80 cent
was when I got arrested maybe eight
wasn't like that sense I owed this guy
sixty large for coke
how much larger diodes because it was
thirty five Aquila huh okay so I was
talking to give me kilo thirty two
assignment that so I was like - I own
his organization right people he dealt
with I owed close to one hundred twenty
thousand easy easy like you hidden but
you didn't know I was getting a Frank J
an agent the one that you got together
you money to that [__]
yeah and I found that a old [__] the
kid money so I'll never forget when I
got separated from my wife I'd I've went
to the car and I drove up to Aspen I
parked the [__] car
who the [__] that I bump it off three
minutes after I was walking his name was
Jay Frederick's look at that I'll never
forget his name and he came up to me and
he goes we I gave him a hug like what
happened I searched him for weapons I
gave the hug right to make sure yeah he
was at some broad and how you doing why
do you live now like nothing happened
they don't say can I ask you a question
what ever happened to that morning I go
God who knows problem good to see oh
[__] and I just walked away from that
was like oh Jesus crazy right you owe me
70 grand 60 hundred sleep at night I'm
gonna get a [__] phone number from
Leo we send me 30 and wash me off do you
have like the locks on your door are you
nervous at all no Jesus the only time
that the worst time for me was when I
was it was 8045 before God he was
Godfather I had a guy then my guy was
giving gambling information to who was a
big big gambler and he was giving me
money up front to handicap his games and
then his book he died in Nebraska that
was it from Colorado big stockbroker I
said Paul I got a guy in Queens my
cousin works for van Queens you know I
can get you this and that but you gotta
send money up front the whole thing he
said five grand up front I set him up
with God he's organization in Queens
through my cousin I hadn't met John yet
and I got money because I was doing
something called have she
while you bring a gambler in and
whatever okay so I was don't ask you to
this guy so I got a few dollars the
first week John Paul Hicks lost the next
week he loses the third week he loses
and now you know my cousin Albert tells
me you know John's upset this guy's not
paying they go this is like the 80s I
gotta call him you know there's no cell
phones you got a home number and that's
it he's not picking up and I said
finally I got em I said Paul my name is
Johnny Rock Burke I said Paul it's
Johnny I said listen this is not your
[__] your guy in Nebraska these are
real people in New York no I know
Johnny's yeah but yeah you know you you
you can't [__] skip away with your
money you got to pay I promise he's I
really want to bet this weekend I got a
games on a bet so I talked to my cousin
al but I said Paul wants to bet so John
got on the phone and said let him bet
this weekend but whatever he loses this
weekend plus what he owes he's got to
pay Monday and that's it I said no
problem I told Paul the same thing
here's Johnny absolutely he bats bats
bats like he'd be like nine [__] 11
games you know stupid [__] stupid
teams at DePaul versus Creighton like
really you [__] he ends up being down
30,000 but he had the money all right
okay so Paul you know money yes Johnny I
got it
monday comes nothing and the next day
Tuesday they get a check for $500 in
Queens by million this is like the
eighties god he's out of his mind
there's [__] so I get a call this
is Thanksgiving morning I'll never
forget I'm with the family my mother my
mother didn't want me to talk to my my
black sheep cousin al because she knew
he was in the Mafia AJ its Albert I okay
what are you doing nothing MA Albert
listen your [__] guy Paul he sent 500
they're out of their minds Johnson to
Cole you can stay by the phone Sean
calls ten minutes later and those
recordings Uhura Gotti when you hear
that the documentaries I got that and he
said you know a bunch of things
basically he said you know you're gonna
go down this [__] guy I didn't get to
become John Gotti because the
[__] like this [__] guy and he
said in a business without ethics we
gotta have ethics I love that
eight minutes the best and then he goes
I'm gonna saying you were your cousin
the Colorado and you're not gonna go
[__] skin you're gonna get my [__]
money
I'm I'm a [__] kid you know I'm 22
years old it was like I can't go to cop
how do you I never wanted to airplane
before I've never even flown to Florida
I'm gonna [__] I was petrified my stomach
was turning Albert's like a.j you better
get this guy and all you to do is call
then I started sending letters because
that's all you could do to let it came
back the [__] house was abandoned
occupant whatever they said I'll keep
him gone there was like a really weird
statement about a month later well
December 14th comes the big hit on
Castellano sparks they cast the whole
thing and Albert says this is a whole
new [__] thing John's the boss the
guy John is not the boss I'm like oh my
god and what does this mean about me you
he goes I don't know and then about a
month later he just said I don't worry
about it solve it John it's gone but you
could do no but they let it go I know
but he just he ate it he ate it he shot
John in it I mean the guy didn't get
killed the guy he ate the [__] and I
didn't get in trouble but then when he
went to his trial in New York by this
time I'm a journalist now for Newsday
91-92 I would go to see his court trials
I wanted to pay my respects and he saw
me and I'm in an elevator with him Sammy
the bull Jackie the nose all these
[__] guys and I remember it I I put
it on my book Sammy who I didn't really
know at all he says Oh John you know
who's this guy like I'm a [__] guy in
the three-piece two-piece suit and a
journalist and he says nah he's all
right he's all right and he said yeah
but he's with them meaning the
journalists and John says he's more
right than them
but the best line more right than them
and I went to the restaurant I was ten
steps behind John Miller we went to jam
bones which is on Mott Street right
across from the courts I had a table
next to John and he told me you're a
good kid who went to college making
mother proud get away from this [__]
so it's very strange when I see him
talking to his son in the [__]
jailhouse thing you know
but to me I was a civilian to him I was
just a kid that got mixed up you know
and he said to me make your mother proud
you know what you don't belong in this
area boy but but then I'm like Michiko
got mixed up with the moms to this and
they beat the [__] out of him and left
him in the street for me to pick up and
I'd vouch for Chico I got him all these
jobs at nightclubs and then I was the
guy on the hook cause you vouch for this
[__] guy oh my god when they're after
you and they manage you there's you know
I don't know how you will you left on
the lam that's feeling of the piteous
stomach when deep when guys are after
you oh my god Tony bet it real quick now
good and let me go first
there was a time I couldn't function if
I wasn't in trouble
that action that rigor yeah that I was a
loser that trigger really so I didn't
like there was a guy used to when I was
a kid II on Joe Mary's oh no not that
one this is Austin North Bergen and he
was a loan shark well and I know he was
somebody once told me Georgian launcher
George the Greek it was really Italian
right in that great George George George
was a loan shark and he had a bartender
named Lila and we would always go in
there we were 15 one day when I was 16 I
just knocked on language or talked to
you for saying here's what I do I need
to borrow 15 owes its 2:54 for it's 10
weeks or $40 okay and I started with
that then I pay him the 400 and then you
know I have to up Stefani and you rent
it then I upped them to a thousand pay
him and one day I went to mom why I need
this amount and it just kept going and
then I would welcome more you know AJ
Benza yeah he needs this amount hey
Janie he doesn't want to ask you
kharbouch room though seeing then I
would go to him in your lease I had you
know like I yeah it comes that nice kid
you got his girlfriend pregnant over a
thousand four girls I had this so I
would pay them from three or four
different accounts you didn't even know
I has used your name what did they it
get you higher something about like new
couch is so important so I would say
Lee's and Irish can come over here but
you want 2000
give me 14 140 a week for not around I
would put you two all in tab oh my god
and I was going to him and then I got to
a point I would just make it up name of
course she busts this dog in my head I
was paying them a different label until
I had them up to like 40,000 left but
job but that so that gets you high that
feeling like that at the time so at that
time that's who I was it was a [__]
creep okay so I never forget going back
eight months later and I go to his bar
because that's where you had to go get
the pills and the coke and I'm in the
back there so every bar has a back door
close to the pool with every school and
I'm not gonna have a glass me and stink
glass I just got off the plane I already
owe this guy 40 G's and on top that I
own another 40 throughout scattered and
I will end to people well you know I
used to rob drug dealers and then they
were too scared to approach me so they
would go to whoever they got the drug
something else and we can't touch him
you go after oh my I had a bunch of
people looking for me for that but the
funniest thing was George or they
knocked in the glass and I'll never
forget great Tabasco looked at me great
a basket look the mingoes what's up it
was George in there what thing always
George in there and also I hear no
George is up here hey George how you
doing here because he lived on top of
the bar am i doing what a [__] of you
been I'm done George good money come on
down he was not be right down dog he
didn't put his head gone I'm gone me and
stinky got in that card he [__] ran
the [__] out of there we had loan sharks
a little loan shark in 79 my mother dies
and they I don't know what the statute
of limitations is where the story is a
story so you get all suck my dick you
got seven you you gotta prove
my mother dies their only greatest
things at 89 my mother 7900 79 Wow
I got a job at a lumberyard okay the
lumberyard is all done paper by my dude
six foot six nice guy huh but in real
life
this thing is owned by a bunch of
different people and at the end and they
would give me boxes every week one of my
job is just to get a box and to go to
the post office and put mail into just
just bills and write you know everything
those days it wasn't computer die wait
you got all your bills in the mail so
now you're building a house and you were
plumb but you got a bill from yeah and
then gonna throw you know a bunch of
letters fell on the floor cause I was
[__] the post cuz I'm just walk out of
corn I've got a bolt oh yeah [__] bum
in the box right there put them in the
box and the card falls out and when they
go to pick it up a hiss oh I'm living
with the Bendis oh my god and and then
there's two credit cards
big-time credit card on one for gas oh
sure I get a scar it's a mobile car to
check some them not gonna tell you the
amount okay and I took the card I didn't
know what to do with the cards or the
amount and I went to a friend of mine
who his brother was half connected at
the time he had just got out of college
the guy but I know he ran in weird
circles the fact he's anyway I meet him
and he I tell my buddy I go and next
thing you know let's go ah I gotta show
you guys something before you leave next
thing you know he's kiss he goes my
brother wants to see you like okay he
comes up to me I give him the two checks
I give him one check is significant the
other check is half of that right but
not bad right and I show him the two
from the mobile card or the American
Express card he looks me in the face he
goes I'm gonna give you grant the
American Express all right see those two
gas card depending on the limit I'll
give you a thousand oh because these are
Italians don't what every
family birthday all the old yeah dog
they know all buy time well I gotta buy
gas my husband time yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they would buy tires and [__] with
it and then the next day he call me
knows I got you cash for the checks I go
how did you catch those checks he goes
that's my business
it was the year that's like it was the
year general letting that shot it was
that week I ever said hey do you want 81
well he made sure it was 20 grand plus
all my monies and he put it in my drawer
that was like my own little ATM machine
oh that's brilliant I would [__] pop
that [__] and then I was telling
these guys here that about 82 when the
first ATM machine I put on my block
oh and from 9:00 to 3:00 if you put you
wanted $20 the twenty would come up but
if you went in there at midnight in
those days you gotta put your card
outside the door would open yes and you
walked in it was i-70 from Bergen line
Avenue don't you know that machine spit
out twenties at me no it's the 210 220
it will give me just one or two hundred
oh and I did this for months
you can't leave for months you can't I
would take my money like totally watch
this one do a gas station
number one guy made him duck the whole
time he was knocking on a back seat what
about the cameras don't worry about the
camera we robbed this ATM machine do you
know I one day the feds showed up in my
house bro oh never like dog you almost
like six grand I'm like I'm like what
are you talking about yeah
no comprende I would think got money out
of a machine really Wow every time you
go the machine is always like that yeah
well I had tons of friends and then let
me paste
I had a friend before the 8th let me say
house how much technology has grown for
you young kids at home oh my god I had a
friend that was a genius he stole like
nothing what he still [__] chicken
yeah well they came to make him money be
an old-fashioned way he was a genius
yep today he has a house yeah I'm sure
he's retired on I know one of his
biggest aim was going to college I
ignore the college he would take every
loan available yeah and what he would do
is he would open up $2,000 bank account
in every line
bang some chase right I don't know who
it was knows yes whatever names on
Thatcher's back America he would put
2005 bank accounts right he will leave
it in there for six months and he would
take a two thousand dollar loan each of
those bank accounts nice I'm the bank so
he would wanna borrow two thousand on
the 2000 I got in there why I don't know
II got ten grand now so he would make a
bunch of payments like - yeah any minute
and then he would pick one every week
and the different aliases she would go
to chase on Friday at 5 to 3 and closed
his account and then he had a
predetermined route to a chase in
Brooklyn who the computer system was too
slow oh my god he would go to chase and
close the account and he had with Chase
in Manhattan so he would do he would
keep closing the account so then I could
go to Suffolk so if the bank was open
till 5:00 whatever account he would
close at 5:00 after 3 this is an 82 guys
83 yeah so he was doubled as my mean it
was just hey I'll slow the process yeah
very computer so if you went to the if
it's over today strictly speaking here I
would close my account at downtown right
and then run to Sherman Oaks she's close
yeah then run to Woodland near half an
hour and close my account there yeah
takes you forever but they wouldn't
catch on til Monday
yeah yeah I see if I'm Friday you do it
they don't catch on what happens on
Monday nothing you're a hit you're a
[__] ago you're done you got you got
your money got it he would take tenth
day he wouldn't make 50 grand all right
right this is how crazy life was that
the sub most and they call these people
rats but they're not right now well that
was a kid every body not like like when
you read a mob book Peter Maass yeah you
wrote a couple books sure where's he
gonna this information from do you think
it's information from the air people
love to talk that's all yeah and you
make sources with certain sources and
stuff like that when you telling stories
that doesn't make you a rat like I had a
cop growing up but I became president
and he would shoot me little things yeah
and I would shoot him little dick right
he would tell me these guys are gonna
have a kilo at their house robbed yeah I
don't like ya
and I would rob him yeah that's only was
breaking my balls right like if I would
rob Li and I heard Lee threaten me I
would put him on wait yeah yeah yeah
listen every Friday at 6:00 lead
delivers a kilo come page and pull him
over
yeah no cut the way listen when I was it
and don't arrest him when I was naked
from when I was like I'm lose the twenty
in 1997 I beat the [__] out of a cab
driver bad I beat him bad I mean broke
his cheekbone his leg
it was horrible I destroyed him in the
street 50 of you and 40s why I was with
my girlfriend and we were late to get
her kid at a kindergarten and this cab
came by and I put my hand up and he was
over he had the light on he didn't stop
she's happened like that he didn't stop
pissed me off and I had a black
girlfriend right
same girl Trump was dating but this is
when I was dating a beautiful black girl
I felt like the guy didn't like that
with this beautiful black girl I thought
something that was in my head he doesn't
like that I'm with this beautiful model
black model he was a [__] like a
Haitian boom he passes me and I give him
the finger he gives me the finger back
and then he stops at a red light so I
run to the red light she goes down to us
and I'll [__] this guy give her a ride
what's your problem
no he starts cursing another [__] and he
spits at me and he hits me in the head
with a spit so I clocked him through the
windows down I knock him in the [__]
face and then he goes down on the
receipt to get something so I open a
door and I [__] destroy him I lay him
out in the front seat just right right
right just destroying him so many times
that people grabbed me off of it because
commuting times 5 o'clock guys go get
all of them where you [__] crazy
gonna kill him I was out of my mind the
girlfriend screaming he comes out of it
and I'm shutting the door the dog he was
bouncing open I'm banging the door boom
bang boom and I go what the [__] his leg
was hanging out of the car
so I broke his shin because I kept slam
like a Pesci move that's why the doors
anyhow yeah
all that the guy gets out of the car
like the [__] walking dead he's
limping at me and I go what is this guy
doing and he he look like one of those
guys at Jake LaMotta fort and Raging
Bull who had nothing left
he throws a looping [__] I ducked
under and I smash him out like a light
knocked out and everybody screaming
I just sat down next to them I tell my
girlfriend get go get Nick from school
I'm staying here
cops come they know who I was AJ the
winner goes to jail loser goes to the
hospital you're going to jail so I was
in the eff jail for the night anyhow I
called my detective friend who I would
always talk to was a journalist he gave
me information I said Dave this [__]
guy he's a Haitian he's a [__]
immigrant look into this guy he couldn't
speak English we got it don't worry
about it
and they go by the time we get to him
he's gonna [__] Shaw he isn't gonna
come after you it's gonna go away so
they go after him and they work them all
though I mean they did they told me now
he worked them all week he's illegal he
ain't gonna say [__] don't worry it's
great thank you
a week later Dave my my detective Dave
older man who worked at Midtown North
him and about five of the cops got
busted because there was a whorehouse
nearby that all the cops would visit and
get [__] and to let the whorehouse
operate there was a sting operation all
the cops who did it
God [__] turn off the fourth they
lost their pension so my guy was one of
the guy that got thrown off AJ I can't
help you I said you gotta be kidding me
the [__] Haitians lawyer heard that
he marched a Haitian into court with the
[__] Walker and the cane and the
eyepatch and everything and I [__]
was guilty and then I played out and
then I got sued from the civil trial
they sued me for 10 million we settle on
80,000 pay this [__] [__] $80,000
the point was I had a cop like that that
happens you got friends in high places
where you giving up beats are you
friends of Jonathan there's no smack me
back I have one of those podcasts two
years ago I said smack me back on the
air no I just do it let it get even yeah
we're friends were fine that was just a
[__] was that 2000 1990 I think was
2000 I smacked it was a
crazy you know there's never straight
without a very real value book that's
why I wanted to read I don't want to I
want to get it to read I gotta know the
next the dis book he had 74 and sunny is
from when I was a kid write the book was
I was out of my mind what was the first
say main and [__] that's the one that
sounds about the pills and the funk yeah
you were right on my life that was out
of my mind
that was a [__] rock star gossip
columnist he I was [__] nuts
now when you were gossip columnist let's
forget about the journalist when you
were gossip comes a bartender that quad
you said I got some information yeah I
did but I you need that I was I was
wired all up yes I blow or something I
didn't do blow in the city I was not my
thing my thing was I was a pain pill guy
I drank and took pain pills I was I
never did cocaine in New York City when
I was a journalist ever I mean ever when
I came to LA I was like oh cocaine is a
currency out here if I get a girl at a
nightclub and she wants to go back to my
house she asked me if I got blow I never
had blow I said I guess I gotta get some
blow like I need scotch or vodka or
[__] club soda
you need cocaine at your house - I never
did coke in New York ever I was tell my
friends if there's coke this [__]
party I'm not taking my nephew I was a
against it but pills sure pills pills
and liquor I was my thing so now with
your podcast are you still doing it is
more gossip sometimes you know Joey it's
I i riff on I'm I'm no different than a
comic I swear to God you know you riff
on things you riff on whatever happening
in the world whether it's Trump or
[__] Hollywood whatever you refine I
look at what's happening in in in in
mainly in Hollywood and I go how can i
connect myself to that story can I get
personal with that story yeah I know
Sean Penn yeah I hung out with so-and-so
so mice my show is a lot about yes it's
gossip but I break stories because I
still have connections to a lot of
people and a lot of my show is about my
personal stories about the people I talk
about so if I'm breaking a story about I
don't know like I do whatever whatever's
happening in the news I can go all I can
make this funny
like for instance Omarosa is talking
about Trump being a racist so for
Monday's show I'm going to talk about
to show I'm gonna talk about I'm the
only person in in the [__] country
who can tell you Trump's not a racist
because we used to date the same black
girl and I know how much he loved her
family and all this you could say what
you want about Trump he might have said
the n-word like I said the N word
doesn't mean racist just calm the [__]
down you know no one else is qualified
to tell that story with me so I'll tell
that story and I'll give I'm Rosa [__]
and I'll tell my story about the girl we
dated bla bla bla so there's always
something that comes up Bethenny
Franco's boyfriend Dennis Shields Odie I
know the Real Housewife people I could
talk on that well I'm my cordial would
always tell me about the purse Jake that
would say she committed suicide because
a boyfriend was gay I did the playmate
who threw a kid out the window
which one you know now because that was
my girlfriend for a while till that was
my Kate Spade and it broke that I broke
no one cares no one cares the guys at
the guys a [__] no one cares
I said I said I got a feeling this guy's
gay so I put the word out with some cops
in the city cuz I still got connections
I said to me favor you know okay she
hung herself whatever but I had a
feeling this guy's gay hey detectives
call me back three days later you know
you're right he has a lover and when the
you know cops want to rule out
everything so detectives looked at
everything they got surveillance tape on
different buildings you know and you
know this guy's keep he keeps coming to
this building with this guy and they'll
even holding hands they're leaving with
this all it was all around there like
guys waste and we took him in a room and
we talked about his you know his
lifestyle and he goes I don't want that
getting out you know I one of the
podcast and said I was right you know
Spade is gay I [__] knew it I don't
know if that's why she killed herself
but I'm sure that's a contributing
factor to not being happily married to a
man who has a male lover and when she
left a note that said ask daddy to her
daughter that's a little [__] weird
it's crazy like ask your father why I'm
Israel or whatever so I thought that was
a good angle to the story nobody in the
mess and the mainstream media writes
that he's gay I don't know I don't know
what to say
okay don't write it I think it's
fascinating that that's a they don't
care
the myth the mainstream media is
terrible now all they care about is how
bad Trump is they don't give a [__]
about stories that are everywhere that I
don't know what they're just the they're
dropping the ball on everything they
just want to talk about how much time a
bad Trump is and how bad America is
doing it's [__] gross there's so many
great stories out there you know going
back to that police thing it's so weird
even more like [__] people [__] with
me I got a cop I call now like the cops
behind my door oh my god sure I just
private investigator now for like a
hundred bucks use like anytime you have
any sane just that's it that's it a
couple weeks ago some [__] idiot said
some tell me like PayPal the guy
yardstick and we fine I get everything
license numbers right [__] blah blah
blah license-plate numbers I get
everything dog where your parents live I
get everything yeah that's real [__]
chamber torture because that's how I
grew up
yeah that's how I was raised you just
don't go for good you go for mine I'm go
for everything yeah [__] take him out
take him out but I go for everything so
it's so weird how we use I used cops you
know it I love Kyle of you know brought
me into the fold Bo Dietl brought me
into OD this was podcast
okay he's coming he's coming come here
yeah yes I'm together bad days here call
me I want to just say hello not to be on
over he's doing a beloved love cuz I
think he's in a movie that's coming out
yeah something all December we did a TV
pilot together for right all the
neighborhood which I don't think is
gonna get picked up but Bose in that no
but Bo that's all you would do but Nick
to Toro Network dude listen he should
think about it we shot two episodes I
swear to god this is good enough to go
on a network
I mean ABC CBS Hulu [__] TBS it's
absolutely good enough it is I'm waiting
to hear any how the [__] Jimmy Russo
Paul been Victor Nick to Toro its way
good enough
it is anyhow well fine what days do you
put your podcast at I'm on now with the
new I'm on page right now so I'm every
day I do a [__] show every day now
and I on top of show every day I also do
well the three free shows a Monday
Wednesday and Friday but my page around
people
to show every day every morning I also
put out on chapters of my untitled book
that I'm writing now I also get that's
why I like what you do that's why I
likes a lot of work I don't want you to
do at all no level it's nicely me
because I started out for free
alright my chairs the game I hate the
admins edges I'm switching I hate the
advertisers but I'd rather well no I
don't want a gun to my head I'm not I'm
not if I was a journalist well I don't
notice I know you've got a good you got
a terrific following no no the following
that years at this behind if I had if I
was a journalist like if I wrote well
took pictures well or even was willing
to take more my [__] now I would have
some type of pantry on well you should
this is where it's worth money it's
worth more what I don't like the time
listen that's great all I do is I record
mostly in court from my home or I go to
a studio and I give people a fifth my
daily shows only 15 minutes but the
three week leaves are 45 minutes but
then I give them the patreon people get
an untitled a chapter from my untitled
book which is like a 30 minute read they
also get classic Hollywood scandals I
did want to Fatty Arbuckle I don't want
Sinatra I did what I give them I give
them a lot so right now it's just
starting it's a good it's a good start
we've got a we got a lot of people that
have joined us to write every day I
write but I write everything getting
addicted I write every shower we've been
thinking of taking the journalism of
course I was going to tell you that I
wanted to call you and go you're writing
a book please look I don't mean let me
help you write but let me give you an
idea how to start each chat because I
know exactly how you think and the way
you tell stories is so great that I can
make your storytelling ability [__]
jump on a page instead of I know how you
all I know you think how do I tell this
story about Chi Chi bus teacher I know
it's like so many different things
coming at you all you do is you pick a
time you say if you if you started at a
nightclub you just say something as
simple as the last fact you're on a
Friday 8:00 o'clock usually looks like
this there's so-and-so on a corner this
one's doing this this is that there's
this happening at this hour on this
particular night boom this
and then get into your story I think
think I think there's easier ways for
you no no no I'm listen easier listen
man I'm learning something that writing
is great it's I did not know I didn't
have the respect I had it's hard to I
thought it was like stand-up well I got
understand them so what I got at this
get him understand them I took those
guys just shut up and got a microphone
ow and then something somebody was there
with a camera no that stuff was fresh I
didn't know that you worked at all right
I didn't know that you had to get on
stage same thing happening we were
writing I thought that you just right
now I tell us Horry now that I read it
and it's [__] pure trash and I gotta
start you know books I've written
already I'm sure I know book I know now
let me take this last three months have
been the best three month writing I can
tell us you haven't talked you haven't
said anything bad about you were
agonizing over for a while 54 I wasn't I
remember I was in debt I listen to me
last note then I know to June 4th
I write live to the personal health I
heard you and there was two weeks after
that it was my head my stomach was
bothering me my conference was down I
was just in the pits and some most
people go see a psychiatrist I didn't I
knew something was wrong and I got a new
notebook right
and I wrote this just right and I just
kept writing it and I saw what was
coming out it wasn't good it was just
coming out and it was lack of confidence
so yeah I lost my bravado that things
that happen I shot the special I saw
Tommy you told me you didn't like this
happen yeah I saw Whitney Cummings on
the stage I want that [__] had
something me out why are you talking
dumb [__] that come to me online
[__] mule yeah I said this is because
I should weakness somewhere right the
weakness it does don't get rid of that
well yeah I'm not going to these places
I went to the improv the other night
just out of because he's a good friend
of mine they got it he's a great kid in
Arsenio fella and he always drove me for
your heart sticks in the tongue great
show right what's his name
Brian monarch I love him to death but
I'm a comedy store guy from now on if
you want to be a green beret get out
that's it if you agree I'm going right
you know I was [__] around and trying
to hang out a different club yeah yeah
not gonna work good for me to get that
energy back okay [__] I was like right
now usually I have a spot yeah and I'm
nervous I'm not nervous mom oh yeah
that's it walk that's it either they're
gonna like it or then [__] up I'm gonna
give them the best 20 minutes of my life
let me get my car go home it's smoking
like I do every [__] day you know
what when I first did the podcast and
then about two weeks ago we started
patreon which is okay you're writing
every day you're giving a show every day
and I just I don't just turn the mic on
and just you know I see you people do
people [__] I have a newspaper or the
terminal that the laptops up and they
read a story and they give their spin on
it I won't do that to my people I don't
I will say I want to write about this
story how could I put myself for this
store who do I know in this angle let me
in and I'll write and I do a podcast
each podcast is generally 12 pages on a
on a laptop that's not easy to do twelve
pages is half a chapter of a book so in
a week to do all my shows I just don't
show up and talk and I could do it I
could fumble and say but when you hear
my pockets you'll never hear me go um
you know what do you call I don't want
to do it like that because a lot of
people know me as the guy on TV that's
scripted that says things the way he
says things so I want to satisfy them I
want to tell them a nice story I want to
you know I just want to come across like
oh it's crisp it's good they listen I
want whatever you charge
I want my value for it all school and
that's it it's a quarter of what yeah
let me use the paper paper yeah it's a
corner a month right pay for might be a
little airport you got a new york post
at the hello I love it it's fine I never
buy exactly if I steal everything when
reports I find you I really am point
doctor nothing not even here Plus
fussing waters is it from [__] Fort
Lauderdale Airport
I know Miami I went to Versailles I got
a couple empanadas and I took these with
the [__] I wouldn't buy all shits but
you know what the people listen to my
show and the same thing as your audience
they get you pomp they get you hype you
let them down so now I'm in contact with
my audience every day with the app and
we're talking all day I can't let them
down you know and when they tell you to
do this to do this there's you go
whatever's going on my life I can't let
those whatever how many people done I
got them I gotta make them happy so I
love it
whenever you feeling lazy you want to
just know I got people want to hear good
[__] so I love it it's the best it's
like getting my column back Joe it's
like I have my car you do I told you
that's the same thing control no no no
y'all [__] again I put that in there I
know him can't this is what computers
for everything what's the name of the
show fame is a [__] right yeah I'm the
[__] fame is a [__] [__] comes out one
day well the free shows up Monday
Wednesday and Friday patreon it's every
day you gotta go to put the patreon app
and get me but yes thought-free if you
want no it's alright ease into the
[__] it's fine I love you
brother I love you too I read that
you're close by I love Brian on the
corner get the [__] shoot this [__]
yeah I love it
alright like I throw in the beginning of
the show blue apron is the way to go
okay they deliver farm-fresh ingredients
and step-by-step recipes right to your
door their mission is to make incredible
home cooking accessible to everybody
okay
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for the ingredients
and building a community of home chefs
okay Lee loves it Lee goes crazy over it
look at this week's menu
you got cheeseburgers with spicy slaw
are you not so what and see a chicken
with tangi barbecue sauce I mean my
mouth is watering as we speak all right
they're quick and easy recipe options
listen they're seasonally inspired the
ingredients mouth-watering grilling
options for the summer
like I said chicken with barbecue sauce
and juicy cheeseburgers with spicy slaw
where you gonna get that at these our
chef designed recipes and exciting
partnerships like with Bob's Burgers and
MasterChef so again check out this
week's check out this menu go ahead do
yourself a favor and you're gonna get
the first three meals for free at blue
apron coms last Joey again that's blue
apron calm slash Joey get your first
three meals free blue apron is a better
way to cook believe in
and they give you the recipe and you
learn how to cook and now you can
impress your friends all right so go to
blue apron and that's all I gotta tell
you all right like I tell you in the
beginning of the show hiring is a
challenge but there's one place you can
go where hiring is simple fast and smart
a place we're going growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place its zip zip recruiter comms last
Church again hiring used to be hard
multiple Java side stacks of resumes a
confusing review process I can't even
think about it but today hiring can be
easy and only you have the one place to
get it done and that's it recruiter comm
slash church you're like Joey why I'll
tell you why because they send you job
to over a hundred of the web's leading
job boards they just don't stop there
with a powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find the people with the right
experience and invite them to apply for
your job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
so zip recruit is so effective that 80%
of its employers who post on zip
recruited get a quality candidate
through the site within one day and time
is money you got a small business you
got a little business a big business
zip recruit is the way to go with
results like that it's no wonder
zip recruit is the highest rated hiring
site in America so right now stop
playing games you're looking for that
and while you're looking for that
employee for the holiday season maybe
the kick in 2019 might as my family the
church family you get zip recruiter for
free what are you saying Joey free at
this exclusive web address you ready
grab a pen and write it down
zip recruiter calm slash Church it's
that easy
zip recruiter calm slash Church si-hu
rch zip recruiter dr. Nam slash Church
the zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire don't forget [__] Thursday
night Huntsville Alabama
that motherfucker's those tickets ago
there was like three hundred tickets so
there's like thirty left so I walk
around and then Friday and sad after you
[__] in Nashville all right don't
forget we do this every Monday morning
to get you [__] started and pump
don't take [__] from nobody today you
understand me stay black have a great
[__] day and I'll see you guys
Wednesday morning stay black love you
take that [__] meal leave